hello everyone and welcome to a most
eventful day of round seven of the
norway chess 2021. now all of the games
are really really awesome but this is
the one that we have to show first it's
a rihan versus sergey karjakin our
leader uh faces the well former world
church championship challenger and it's
a really really an amazing game uh
basically this game is the story about a
past pawn and it's a it's a past c pawn
but it started its journey as a past as
the normal d-pawn which you'll see in
the game so it's a there's quite a lot
to take in let's check it out and uh see
see what happened here so rapport with
the white pieces opens with d4 and uh
for the rest of the game uh pay close
attention to what this pawn does
we have knight to f6 by karjakin c4 we
have e6 knight to c3 and here sergey
goes for bishop to b4 we have the nimzo
indian defense on the board we have
knight to f3 going for the three nights
variation castles and now queen to c2
so now if the bishop captures you don't
have to capture with the beep when you
can capture with the queen but also you
add some additional support to the e4
square so you can maybe uh launch
forward with e4 at some point so d5 by
black we have bishop to g5 uh nicely
developing and h6 black is asking what
do you want to do with the bishop do you
want to move back or do you want to
capture on f6 uh bishop captures an f6
display this is considered the main idea
uh queen captures and now a3 now you
have to capture on c3 because uh well
both the c pawn and the knight will be
uh attacking that d5 square so the
knight has to be captured now we're
gonna capture with the queen we have d
captures on c4 and now uh forcing white
to recapture with the queen uh sort of
wasting another tempo uh instead of
maybe playing a move like e3 and bishop
captures on c4 but okay this has all
been played before and nothing uh you
know
funny is happening here so c6
uh aimed at the idea that white is
preparing g3 and bishop to g2 so the c6
pawn will do a very nice job of
controlling the slight square bishop so
this is what our upper goes for we have
g3 knight to d7 and now
there's uh there are some games where
queen to c3 was played because of course
the knight has many options in the
future of attacking this queen but here
we have uh not bishop to be a bishop to
g2 but bishop to h3 this is a new move
by rapport
and it is now uh only as of move 12 that
we have a completely new game so let's
see uh how uh karakin continues this uh
if uh rook to e8 would be an interesting
idea uh simply continuing and then maybe
you know
just trying to figure out what to do
then maybe the knight comes to b6 but
it's not easy
because uh
what what is it really doing there okay
you are preparing a move like e5 the
knight is very well positioned
but other than that it's um well it's
not a pleasant position you have to
develop the light square bishop and also
get this rook into the game you could
also consider a move like g5 it's also
possible uh maybe at some point you know
even h5 and g4 since white plays placed
this bishop so weirdly on h3 but here we
have c5 and this is where the fun really
begins now we have d captures on c5
rapper grabs the pawn and now b6 here uh
karjakin wants um to give up the b6 pawn
as well and then we would have something
like c captures knight captures attacks
the queen let's say queen c3 we offer a
queen trade calculus captures and bishop
to b7 and this is the game he wants to
play he would be down upon but he would
have um
you know a very nice position the rooks
are going to c8 and d8 the white has
three pawn island so black would
definitely have compensation for the
sacrifice pawn but rapper decides
against this pawn grab and he advances
this pawn to c6
and okay we already have a very nice
pass pawn on c6 but it's uh i mean can
it really survive there uh we have queen
captures on b2 now saying okay if you
capture my knight i'm gonna capture your
rook so here we have castles now the
rooks are connected and defending each
other and only now knight to c5 so here
we have knight the d4 now again this
knight is very nice at this point is
very nicely defended and rook to d8 now
with a double attack on the knight here
we have e3 defending and now how do you
continue here well one thing you could
do is uh play e5 and that's definitely a
question whether you should allow this
knight to remain here
and then allow something like bishop
captures on c eight for example e5
bishop capture so we would capture with
the rook rookie captures and see it and
then maybe knight to f5 uh going for
that e7 square i mean you can't capture
the pawn because 97 picks up the pawn so
the pawn is always kind of
it here uh so instead we have bishop to
a6 attacking the queen here and
connecting with the rook and now queen
to b4
saying that uh okay i'm attacking your
queen what do you do
and the thing is if the queen is
captured we're gonna catch with eight
captures on b4 and now yes we could
capture the rook on f1 but then bishop
captures on f1 the knight is still stuck
here uh and after let's say i move like
knight to e4 we're gonna play bishop to
a6 and now we're to play c7 c8 our
bishop already controls the c8 square
and white will have a better game here
uh so instead after queen to b4 we have
knight to d3 now attacking the queen
and the queen captures on b2 now the
queens get traded off the board knight
captures on b2 and now rook f2b1 putting
pressure on the knight here so knight to
a4 and now f4 uh now rapper says if you
didn't play e5 uh up until this point
you're not playing it now my knight is
now a solid here on d4 and this pawn is
beautiful here on c6 so here we have
knight to c3 attacking white's rook here
and this is where you really should go
into a deep thing because a lot of
things are possible and we're on only
briefly going to discuss it since it's
uh well uh it's it's uh it's a position
that's uh
even you know it would it would take a
couple blanca with infinite time on the
clock to uh kind of really go through
this position in the game rook to b2 was
played but what's uh what's really
exciting is rook to c1 and here many
good things might happen so here the
idea is that if white goes for rook to
c1 attacks the knight then if knight
moves you have a beautiful pass pawn
here already real behind it uh
karakin's idea was most probably rook
captures on d4 and then after pawn
captures knight to e2 check forking the
key in the rook and after the king moves
knight captures rook captures and now we
have this position where uh well you we
have a pass pawn we have a rook behind
the passport but it's sufficiently
defended by the bishop and by the rook
and
it's a very complicated for example king
to f8
we can even play d5 here there are many
hidden resources here in the position
and if he captures on d5 now c7 now our
bishop also controls this square so
bishop to c8 has to be played and now
the rook is out of the game for the
moment and then the game can continue
you know in a lot of ways but white
should have a very good game bishop to
g2 you go after the pawn
and well it's just just a very nice
position to
enjoy for white uh of course it could
continue many other ways but it's uh
definitely the main move to consider
rapport goes for rook to b2 and this is
also a very fine line uh however a very
different one because it allows black to
really consolidate the position so here
knight to d5 now uh karayaki wants to
play knight to c7 and forever block this
pass pawn king to f2 improving the
position of the king defending the e3
pawn and now knight back to c7
and here what do you do well there's so
much to consider here because it's not
easy getting this knight away from c7
you don't have any way of controlling
the dark squares uh this pawn is very
nice here but it's just blocking your
own bishop and it's it's very hard to
continue this game for example if bishop
the g2 which is the engine's absolute
favorite move then black kinda gets
uh the possibility of activating with e5
at upon sacrifice and after f captures
we're gonna play rook here attack the
pawn and now we have to defend it with
knight to f3 but now we had to move our
knight away from this beautiful d4
square now rook 8 to d8 and black kinda
fully activated for the price of that
one pawn
in the game however rapper played rook
to d1 he wants to double up on the d
file and karjakin says that's exactly
what i'm going to do we have rook to d6
rook b to d2 and now rook 8 d8
and now king to e1 defending this uh uh
rook if the knight moves then you can
trade off
both pairs of rooks and now you are
preparing e4 so bishop to c4 and now we
have e4 uh we have f6 black wants to be
the one to play uh e5 he doesn't want to
allow white to get all of his pawns on
dark squares and then this bishop will
be just a monster on the light squares
so here bishop to g2 and now e5 this
kind of blocks this bishop in and
doesn't allow both the bishop and the
knight to keep an eye on the c6 spawn so
f captures an e5 f captures and not
knights to f3 so putting pressure on the
e5 pawn but now karjakin just trades
everything along the d file captures
captures we have captures captures and
now bishop to b5 going after the spawn
and knight captures an e5 so white is up
upon but of course karaki knew this and
he had to go into this if he wanted to
activate his pieces and just get rid of
all the tension and now he has a clear
way of what he wants to do he wants to
get the king to d6 and then just pick up
the c6 pawn equalize the material and
just uh you know get a get a nice draw
and maybe you know push for something in
armageddon so came to a f8 and now we
have h4 king the e7 now comes knight the
g6 with check this is a very cool little
trick king to d6 and now e5 with check
the knight controls the e5 square and
the bishop now covers the c6 square so
the king cannot capture yet king to c5 i
hope you guys are still keeping an eye
on this pawn because it survived for a
very long time and it might survive even
longer
we have knights to e7 now adding another
defender here and now king to d4 so this
is now a very active king
knight the c8 going after the a7 pawn
and now uh black uh will capture on e5
uh you could also consider something
like a5 uh but then the b6 pawn falls so
there's that so here king captures and
e5 was played knight captures on a7 and
now king back to d6 now again if the
knight moves we're gonna capture the
pawn here but not really because the
knight moves with check and now of
course the king still can't capture the
bishop covers the pawn king to c5 and
now knights to e7 again we're double
defending this pawn here
and now we have knight to e6 uh well if
you continue with king to d6 then you
allow this knight to f5 check and then
after king to c5 we would capture on g7
and now yes you can finally win this
spawn uh but the then is just a lost
game captures captures knight here and
you will win this pawn and you will be
up uh two points of course in a
completely winning position if this
knight g7 you pick up the pawn you have
to connect it past pawns of course
completely winning so after 1987 we
still can't figure out how to get this
pawn we play knights to e6 and now comes
king to c3 we have king to d6 chasing
away the knight trying to win this pawn
but now king the b4 so what do you play
here uh well again uh it's uh not uh not
a pleasant situation uh we have bishop
back to a6 here uh the key defending
move for black is knight to d4 it's a
beautiful idea because it defends the
bishop uh we you now have a triple
attack on the c6 pawn and also you are
preventing knight to f5 check then we
can simply pick up pick up that knight
but in the game karayaki played bishop
to a6 and now he allows it
knight to f5 check
king to e5 and now bishop to h3
uh so defending this knight
and now if you go back king to d5 then
the problem is that we have this king
the c3 move and now if you capture this
pawn now we have knight captures on h6
and then again the knight is hanging if
you capture
this knight and white again has
excellent chances of winning the game so
instead we have h5
uh kind of getting this knight away so
now maybe we can kick away the knight
without leaving him any targets but now
knight to e3 so what do you play here we
have knight back to c7 uh and now bishop
to g2 so this pawn still surviving hope
you guys are paying attention to this
spawn we have g6 and now comes a4 by
white uh we have king d4 attacking the
knight knight the c2 with check king e5
now king to c3 we have king to d6 again
uh trying to put some pressure on the c6
pawn but now bishop to e4 going after
this pawn here and now comes bishop to
e2 there's no good way of defending the
g6 pawn so what you play here there's uh
basically only one move that allows a
white to safely win the game so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this uh
well uh improving move with the knight
it's not a move with the knight back
unfortunately it's the move with the
knight forward uh so congratulations on
being a great end game player yet again
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's knight to d4 we
don't want to grab the pawn greedily
right away first we defend our own pawn
and then we're gonna go after this spawn
so what can black do not much king the
e5 putting pressure on the bishop also
preparing knight to d5 check to try and
get the king away from the defense of
the knight on d4 so bishop captures on
g6 now knight to d5 with check we have
king to d2 uh and now bishop the g4 our
bishop is also hanging so knight to b5
now
uh
keeping an eye on the c7 square now
we're ready to push it and now knight to
e7 attacking the bishop here and just
bishop to e8 so now we're again
defending the pawn and preparing to push
our pawn to c7 we have bishop to f3
attacking the pawn twice but the just c7
we have bishop to g4 we have to keep an
eye on the c8 square now comes bishop to
f7 a beautiful move you can see that the
bishop and the knight are preventing the
king from reaching uh
the past pawn so here we have knight to
c6 and now well i don't even have to ask
you to pause the video here because i
know you guys are realizing that our
good friend the light square bishop is
overloaded here you can't keep an eye on
c8
and the h5 both uh so here there's a
really uh no no good move if you try
something like king f6 instead of this
that uh maybe harass the bishop just
bishop c4 and you can see that all of
these squares are taken away from the
black king there's no way to approach
the past pawn so knight the c6 was
played like i said and now comes bishop
captures on h5 of course that's
all there needs to be done and he was in
this position and move 59 that uh sergey
koryakin resigned to the game and
another impressive victory for rihar
rapport in classical time format which
is just incredibly impressive he's still
leading the tournament
ever since round one and that's just
amazing in in the competition that he's
playing uh and as you can see our good
friend the c pawn is still standing and
there's really no hope uh
of anything here if you capture the
bishop we're just gonna promote this
pawn to a queen
and if you don't do that for example you
move the bishop back then we just move
our bishop back and start pushing our
past pawns of course we are up three
pawns it's a way it's a very easy win
there's nothing you can do about this
so yeah after night sorry after bishop
captures on h5 akariakin resigned and
another very impressive victory for
rapport
uh what does this mean for his uh
classical rating well uh he overtook a
lot of people he overtook geary and
wesley so and he's currently number six
in the world classical uh uh rating list
uh he is uh trailing um uh uh by by some
four points uh uh to reach eleven eleven
arunan uh and then it will take some
additional 12 points to reach
but you know he the way he's playing i
guess it's possible he could emerge
world number four even after this
tournament we'll see we'll see what
happens can he continue this up until
the very end
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it like i said all of the games today
were great we're going to show at least
one more so stay tuned for that uh i
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to er er maggita avida i hope you hope
you had a good one uh and i would like
to thank tom keaching steven chinley uh
usetalk8.com and cosmicjust.com for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
amazing tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day